relationships are your greatest resource
view are allowing weaknesses mistakes
traumas who didn't love you who wasn't
there for you they'd stand by you to
define you everything I ever experienced
I had to build from the ground up need
motivation watch a top ten for believe
nation what's that belief nation it's
Evan I believe in you and this channel
is designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
on today's lessons from a man who spent
his teenage years caring for his father
dropping out of university to then
become a pastor a best-selling author
and filmmaker who's inspired millions of
people around the world to find their
potential he's Bishop TD jakes and
here's my take on his top ten rules a
success vol 4 also if you want to know
what Bishop Jake's and other
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check that my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below that's why I deal
with people who cannot pick up the pace
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one use your head when God gives you an
opportunity instead of just jumping on
the opportunity you're supposed to see
what it can be I tell him all the time
you know God God never made not one
table yeah I love this do this this is
nice good God never made a chair and all
of his years of being God he's never
made a chair he's never made the table
he just made a tree and the rest of it
was up to us when God has you a tree
imagine a table a chair imagine a wall
in a room
imagine a log cabin imagine what it can
be imagine
so I'm in South Africa and I'm on a
safari and I'm really like tricking out
for this safari and I'm out here with
all of these big animals and stuff and I
love this elephant this one around the
elephant is strong and he's big and it's
tough and his powers and his weight
they throw his weight around he throws
his weight around what can you do with
it because he's so big
God made him big as a defense the lion
roars when he roars everybody is almost
paralyzed in fear because God gave him
his roar as its defense the cheetah says
I can't raw like that but I can run like
the wind
the Cheetahs food he goes running
through the woods because God lead him
able to run because that's his defense
the eagle spreads its wings and soars
into the air and says I can't run but I
can fly we've gotta let dingo be able to
fly because it was his defense and I'm
walking around in the jungle and I said
well Lord I can't fly like the eagle
I can't run like the cheetah I can't
roar like the land and I can't throw my
weight around like the elephant what did
you give man as his defense in the whole
ecosystem of human of life force what
did you give me he said I gave you a
brain your brain is your defense that's
why God didn't make chairs he only
brings it halfway and then lets you
imagine collaboration develop you have
to say what I'm saying the problem with
church people is that we are taught that
God makes furniture so we pray and pray
and pray
I want you to look around your life for
trees not tables God's gonna bring it
within the reach of your mind
and your creativity is gonna take it the
rest of the way and it's gonna turn into
apps and it's confirming the Apple
phones and it's gonna turn the computers
this concern into satellite systems in
my heaven look at what all we were able
to do lo other but no other creature no
other species and send satellites up
into the air created smartphones look at
what we did with rule number two leave
your comfort zone let's talk about the
Eagles for a minute because the the
mother Eagle after sitting on eggs
protecting it with her life until they
hatch and going out and swimming an
attacking prey and bringing back food
until they grow then turns around the
same beat that fed them and the same
body that warms him takes him out to
cliffs and throws him over the edge it
is not that she has turned against her
children but she knows that they will
never find their wings and safety
the eaglet learns to fly by confronting
it's scary place and it's not even
trying to fly it's falling and flapping
and think your mama is crazy
I've called Child Protective Services I
gotta get out of this but in the process
of falling and flapping and falling and
flapping them falling and flapping and
flapping and flapping and flapping come
on flapping and rule number three focus
on the vision you wouldn't be in this
room if you didn't have a vision he
wouldn't be in this room I didn't ever
be worried about the vision Lord than
the provision I find that the vision the
provision comes to the vision a lot of
people I asked for provision who have no
vision and and money runs from blindness
money runs from blindness yes here money
runs from blood it's money Bishop you
might need to unpack that one okay well
for some if there if there is no purpose
there is no provision and and and I'm
not talking about physical blindness I'm
talking about blindness so far as career
and future until you figure out the
first thing the bank wants to know is
what do you want to do anybody who's
gonna invest in you wants to sit here
what do you see what do you see when
jesus healed the blind man in touch with
you the first time he asked him what do
you see because his response is based on
his answer so the men said I see man
walking as trees each of them touch you
again until I clear up your vision we
can't leave this spot
if you the first time I went to break it
it was amazing
they wanted a seven-year projection of
our company and I thought wow I didn't
know anything about business I thought
what in the world do they want therefore
I could write down anything what they're
really asking you is have you thought
through the future they're asking you
can you see because if you can see we
will fund what you see pro vision but if
there is no vision how can there be
provision so we when we want something
ask God for provision but you need to be
asking for vision because if you get a
clear vision and you're passionate about
it
people support people not ideas so if
you're not excited about it why should I
give to it rule number four be present
in the moment I was telling about your
Sunday if you go to my stream and
straight and stream our service Sunday
you get to see a big ugly six foot two
man start whimpering and lips start
trembling got you buddy
cry yeah I had no idea when I was
pastoring in Smithers forty people fifty
people some others West Virginia on
Easter on Easter on Easter
forty is a piece of right now Easter Egg
Easter that's gotten pregnant folks in
the numbers we had about fifty people
I wasn't I had no idea that the potter's
house was in me you stumble into yeah
but until you dignify the forty you
don't get the forty thousand the
property today is that people are so
busy going after the forty thousand that
they don't respect the forty and if you
don't do your best with the forty you
won't get to the forty thousand so all
of my life I stumbled into relationships
and situations and circumstances that I
had no idea we're going to happen in my
life but as you dignify the present with
your attention and like that to be
present in the moment I like that that
is so important sometimes I have to make
myself do it because I'm such a planner
I'm so strategic I'm really pin years
ahead of word the calendar is right now
I'm waiting on to catch up I got plans
rule number five be effective I never
wanted to be famous I prayed to be
effective Wow
yeah I prayed to be effective you are
you are you know all I found out that if
you are an effective effective will
bring Fame a frame that's not anything
to be frame it's not anything to aspire
toward it is something that you endure
yes something that you endure frame robs
you of something that money cannot buy
normalcy privacy seclusion which is a
healthy part of mental health to be able
to have sabbaticals away from crowds
even Jesus escaped crowds and tabs to
renew himself so to all of you that are
that might be out there thinking you
know God make me famous change that
prayer today it's far better to be
effective and I tell people all the time
everybody famous is it great and
everybody graded in famous a lot of
people are afraid to build from the
ground up because we are shown instant
success
yes overnight wonders yes somebody put
something on YouTube and they exploded
and now they're famous and then we got
people who are famous for being famous
it used to be you were famous because
you're worse you did something loud you
just find this you just find this oh
yeah and we got everybody who wants to
walk around and just be famous but but
the first thing God said wasn't be
famous it was be fruitful right be
fruitful yes and it being fruitful makes
your famous events okay rule number six
don't hold yourself down and it is not
what you think about God that is holding
you it is what you think about you that
is holding already let me try it on
there it is not what you think about God
that is only you you got great thoughts
about God it is what you think about you
that keeps bringing you back down to
playing the same role in the same movie
over and over again you will not accept
God script God has a script for you to
go by you will not accept God script
because you are allowing weaknesses
mistakes traumas who didn't love you who
wasn't there for you who didn't stand by
you to define you and you are letting
the enemy script you for the life Jesus
died to give you rule number seven
develop good relationships relationships
are your greatest resource
people who don't like money don't like
resources because everything that's I
ever gonna come to you is gonna come
through a person that's why you got to
be careful how you treat people because
it's not guarantee that it'll be
somebody you like your friend they won't
necessarily be your color and they may
not have your theology okay but God may
use them to bless you
rule number eight tap into your
creativity if you didn't get a good job
you have to created the job come on yeah
yeah you have to carve out a niche in
the earth for yourself and be creative
you must realize that we were created by
create or who created us in his likeness
and in His image and if our Creator is a
creator then I have to be creative
somewhere down inside of every single
solitary person in this room is
creativity whether you tap into it or
not we were not meant to follow a
marching band and follow it behind other
people's creativity and not discover our
own you have creativity you have passion
and you have purpose and giving people
the freedom and the world with all to
build that I suddenly realized when I
sat down to write this book bed
everything I ever experienced I had to
build from the ground up I never
inherited anything I mean my father gave
me a watch and and I appreciate it and
you know my parents weren't so much into
what they left to you but they were
masterful at what they left in you rule
number nine have an entrepreneurial
mindset soar when I sat down to write it
was written solely and exclusively to
people who had aspirations for being
entrepreneurial because I grew up in a
home with entrepreneurship and I'm very
passionate about it and I've expressed
it to my children as I began to write it
I thought this is also true for people
who are starting churches the same land
said was applicable because a nod to a
person who goes to work goes to work to
perform a task and when the task is over
they go home an entrepreneur doesn't
have hours an entrepreneur takes full
responsibility for everything you can't
be one-dimensional and be an
entrepreneur just because you like to
bake cookies doesn't mean that you can
just think about baking cookies you got
to think about packaging you got to
think about marketing you got to think
about health inspections you got to
think about stamp developing you have to
think about everything the buck stops
with you so you have to be a global
thinker to be an entrepreneur we are
taught we are teaching people to be
specialists in one dimension and it was
very much like pastoring a church
starting a church you started a church
you can't just worry about what I'm
gonna preach is something there are
preachers who who come to work for
churches who are so organized that they
are hired to preach but if you started
church you better be hard to clean
bathrooms you better be hard to drive
the bus you better be hard to balance
the books you have to be hard to do a
lot of stuff you know I worked my way
out of doing all this stuff
I started out you know I was a choir
director at the head of the Deacon board
to clean up community at the janitorial
service and the marketing director I had
to be everything that's an
entrepreneurial mindset and I continued
to write the book I realized and I
wasn't talking about a thing I was
talking about a mentality but the
mentality says I take responsibility for
where my life is going well so I wrote
the book sword to say to you whether
you're working a job and need when you
work a job I tell you what I'll pay you
but what I'm willing to pay you may not
be how much you need to make so you
might need multiple streams of income in
order to get what you are really worth
even though I've determined what I'm
going to pay you you cannot allow my
evaluation and assessment of what you
are worth to my company stream to be the
substratum of what you hope to get for
your dream and your purpose understand
so whether it is subsidizing your income
with multiple streams of income as I've
mentioned to you while I'm sitting here
talking to you we're filming in
Pittsburgh you don't always have to be
present to be productive okay
I talk in the book about building the
team around you in building I call it
the machine building the machine is
imperative for you to be functional the
only reason I can sit here right now is
that I have a team of staff people who
are sending me takes up to the very last
minute before I walked out here telling
me what's going on in all the venues all
the time all the while what's being shot
what's being handled all that's going on
you have to build around you and
infrastructure and this is what the
reason one of the reasons I wrote the
book is I watched my father started a
business with the mop of the bucket the
one mop one bucket borrowed a truck went
to clean up a place and turn it into a
business with 52 employees and Tim truck
service in the state of West Virginia
doing a janitorial service and one of
the things that stopped it from going
nationwide in my view is that he
wouldn't stop mopping do you understand
what I'm saying
my father was such a hustler and a good
sense he was a good hunter he was it was
hard to describe what he did because he
did everything to survive his 1960 and
then when he started working he was good
at working took pride in what he did but
in order to really get your hand on
things things you have to stop doing and
start being the John Maxwell says if you
know how to do a thing you will always
have a job but if you know why they're
doing it they will always work for you
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is don't let
fear hold you back as a young boy I was
enthralled by airplanes and the wonder
of whether I would ever embark on a
flight that would carry me to new
exciting adventures and a life of
limitless possibilities I came to know I
had the power within me to soar and that
has made all the difference in my life
flying for the first time is a lot like
creating your own business launching a
start-up or establishing a
non-for-profit
organization both require a leap of
faith and a willingness to take a
journey of unexpected variables in other
words both require a little bit of crazy
and a whole lot of courage don't let
fear hold you back from doing what you
truly love commit to your visa and be
the CEO of your future
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Bishop Jake's on how to just do it
that I think you're gonna really enjoy
but before that is time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
your business and if you're feeling bold
answer these questions in the comments
below here we go question number one
what is fear holding you back from doing
number two how can you tap into your
creativity to conquer that fear and
number three who in your circle of
friends can hold you accountable
everything in my life I stumbled into he
said right I stumbled into I'd never
thought I would be producing films my
wife and I started out doing gospel
plays and going on tour during gospel
place we had no intention that we were
going to ever do movies we were trying
to do plays and trying to figure out how
to do that right and losing and losing
money we went to Atlanta and and just
lost our shirts for the first play and
and in the process of stumbling around
we finally figured out how to get the
play kind of going good and then I met
this dude but I said let's collaborate
and do it together and the dude was a
publicist named Tyler Perry Tyler Perry
was fresh out of sleeping in his car
right and I was fresh out of money and
so we got together and collaborated and
did a play call woman our loose Reuben
cannon was in the crowd and he saw the
play and he said I want to make it a
movie he said I want to make it a movie
I didn't have mine I didn't have no
movie money
and money both start with the in for a
reason
you can say you have one you got to have
the other but he said something to me
that becomes the way business people
think they don't fail to do something
because they don't have the money he
says we'll raise some money let's do the
movie listen at the different attitude I
can't do it cuz I don't have the money
he doesn't see money as an issue if you
see it as an issue it'll be a stop sign
we put the money together and we did
this little low-budget phone film women
are loose and this sort of whim
submitted it to the Santa Barbara Film
Festival and on the festival and all of
a sudden the movie that we were gonna
put on TV went to screen you see how
you're stumbling into it isn't it's not
always said she planned it but if if you
honor where you are with your best
effort even if it is not it it will lead
to it so as you walk along you stumble
into it if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you Apple
that would be can like a little beacon
[Music]
if you want more Bishop Jake's check out
the first top 10 they have a bit on him
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there if you
don't know who you are somebody can
ascribe any identity on to you and you
would morph into whatever they want you
to be